she is a global economist an author on
edge of chaos why democracy is failing
to deliver economic growth and how to
fix it Denby some oil congratulations on
your book terrific I think you have the
right topic I'm also worried about
democracies dying tell me why so many
people aren't concerned and like it
seemed when you say democracy is in
trouble I think a lot of people it seems
so abstract how do we make it personal
to them and and let them know it's
important in their actual lives well
there are a whole host of factors that
are suggesting that democracy under
siege for one thing voters participation
rates are down considerably they're
around 50% everywhere here well mainly
the United States is the vanguard of
liberal democracies so I'm particularly
focused on the US but of course across
Western Europe where democracy is also
prevalent we are seeing very low
participation rates um for low-income
households even worse it's some less
than 30% by some studies and the deep
concern there is that this is really far
from the one-man one-vote mantra of
democracy but the other issue is that
money has seeped into politics there
about 158 families in this country that
are responsible for 50% of the of the
political contributions of the president
in 2016
lobbying has doubled in the past couple
of decades people feel disconnected
absolutely disaffected and you know
there's studies from pew the think-tank
that 80% of Americans just don't even
trust the federal government to do
what's right in a regular basis and we
don't really teach civics anymore so I
think I don't think people know what's
missing because they didn't know what
was there to begin with I think that's
absolutely right and you know issues
around civics and education but also
there really no minimum standards for
being a politician anymore and the way
that they used to be no we don't have
politicians who have experience in
agriculture as farmers and teachers and
lawyers and we now have professional
politicians and I think that's a great
disservice to us as well so a lot of
people around the world younger people
they look to China now because China
gets things done
but it's not a democracy
so you're hitting on exactly the central
part of a thesis of my book which is
this myopia in political liberal
political systems is particularly
problematic all the problems that the
global economy in the United States is
facing over the next decades our
long-term intergenerational problems
things like the amount of debt income
inequality worsening the risk of
Technology killing off jobs I mean those
are all very very deep structural
problems and yet our politicians are
very short-term they're thinking about
the next election and this creates this
gives you how do how do we make them not
do that how do we I mean that's been but
really I mean that's why China succeeds
because I'm of course you know if you
have a dictatorship you don't have to
ask somebody if we should do it they go
well let's let's switch from coal and
let's do it tomorrow and they can do
that or they can bring people out of
poverty which they have yes but you
don't want to live in a country oh I
wouldn't want to live in a country with
that exactly we live here because we
want but they can't think 25 years ahead
we don't think 25 months ahead yes how
do we incentivize politicians I think
that we can incentivize them by linking
their pay to longer-term outcomes I
think one of the problems here is well
their compensation I think should be
higher but they should be forced to
justify their compensation just the way
we are forced to come more so we don't
get the dregs in that right exactly but
in Singapore for example you know the
politicians are actually paid bonuses at
the end of the year based on long term
outcomes what happened to life
expectancy what happened to GDP I mean
in this country are politicians yeah we
paid we get people like this Scott
Pruett guy you know this kind of head of
the EPA who I think he's in government
just because this is as good as it's
gonna get I'm flying first-class you
know he's in it for the purpose well you
know I think there's been so much of a
revolution around compensation in revit
sector I don't see why we shouldn't
apply such stringent rules to the public
sector as well but some of your fixes
for democracy sounds like going
backwards or at least they sound like it
maybe they're not but you're talking
about weighted voting which is where
some people who are experts but how do
you determine that sometimes get more of
a vote and what they used to call a poll
tax you know giving people an example
or they can vote I can certainly see
this yeah I hear you huffing and puffing
already I I heard that we certainly
don't want that I mean I think I'd be
the first person disenfranchised if I
actually started proposing weighted
voting so we don't want it in a way that
does adjective such as wealth or race or
gender are the guidelines but as an
immigrant coming to this country you are
required to take a civics test and write
essentially I think it's really about
showing engagement and caring about the
civics civics some and also the
political process and that's really what
I think is worth considering